so what do i call you
um
just go by hillary clinton yeah
all right hilary
hillary uh where are you from originally
where'd you grow up
i was born in houston texas but i went
from there and i was two years old
and then i
basically moved out here to california
and i grew up in visalia fresno area
which is about two hours north from here
i lived there ever since you're telling
me you're living in l.a now yes i am i
just moved from arizona here got it
and uh
tell me about your childhood you grew up
with both your parents
i did not
so i actually got taken away from them
when i was two years old that's why i
had moved from texas and then
i went and lived in nebraska from two to
seven with foster family
and then thankfully my biological
grandmother ended up adopting me when i
was seven years old but unfortunately
she had passed away a year later
so then i got passed down to my
biological mother's sister my aunt and
she's who i call my mother who raised me
and that is my mother
and i've been with her ever since what
happened to your actual parents
they're still i know that my dad lives
in san diego apparently um my mom
actually when i go back to visalia i see
her on the road in a tent just doing her
drugs
so they're she's not doing well still
yeah
so how was your childhood otherwise
um honestly
it was a it was well but i really don't
remember much from you know like seventh
grade below like i think a lot of my
brain blocked it out or something
because i don't really remember much of
it
was there any kind of abuse during your
childhood or anything like that
um um
yeah um
one of the reasons i was actually taken
away from my parents when i was younger
um
apparently my mother had walked in on my
dad
musting me and
i was damn near only like three years
old so jesus
um i don't remember it obviously because
i was very young and as i said
previously i don't remember a lot from
like seventh grade below
um
that was another reason
she had like let like cps and like know
about that too
so
yeah
i mean i don't remember much like i was
saying but
it's not an easy topic yeah but
but what i do remember it was it was
nice with the foster family
yeah you had
some rough rough roads there
what um
so you got into stripping at what what
age
right when i turned 18. 18.
i'm 25 now
and you
worked that was what city
um san luis obispo so after i turned 18
i about two days two days later i got up
moved out of my parents house
and went to san luis obispo and i
started working doing outgoing parties
because in san luis obispo they actually
don't have any strip clubs the closest
one is like in
santa
santa something and it's still like 30
minutes away
um so i just did outgoing party like
bachelor parties birthday parties and
all that and there's a lot of work in
sales bispo because a lot of people go
there for like their bachelor parties
it's very well known for that
and very expensive town and
fun and all that wine country
right next to it so
i just started doing bachelor parties
and all that stuff and i still currently
do that so but out there is where it
started yeah
and
str uh
what do you call it stripping
exotic dancer what it was not a dancer
it's always weird putting on your
application for work like if you want to
get a real job like what do you do and
i'm like entertainer
so how do you find that as a career is
it is it you get treated nicely by the
guys your customers um yeah a lot of
them are really nice and then
a lot of them
know what you're doing know what you
want like we know this girl's just here
talking to me for the money i'm not
really what she's saying i am
but it's always a hit or miss
yeah yeah
and you make good money at it
yeah pretty decent money like when i was
doing the bachelor parties i was making
19 hour plus tips so
i would go home with like four or five
hundred dollars in an hour which is what
i like about doing the outgoing parties
because you're always guaranteed it an
hourly wage or an hour whatever you want
to call it
um rather than at a club
you don't you can work for an hour and
not get paid a single dollar like it
always depends on who's coming in like
if you have your regulars or not and all
that
what are the downsides of being an
exotic dancer
when you want to get them into like the
vip rooms and stuff as i was mentioning
earlier to you yeah um you gotta
you gotta sell it you gotta
tell them oh yeah you're gonna get this
you're gonna get that you can get
whatever you want and then you get back
there and you don't do any of what you
said
and they get a little pissed but they
already paid up front so you already
made your money
but then you just got to sit there and
hear a [ __ ] or let them just roll with
it so do you have kids of your own i do
not you don't actually have two boys my
two fur babies
two dogs yeah got it and uh
so do you find having relationships
tricky with the career that you have um
yeah
some a lot of people are judgmental
about it and then
a lot of people
they praise me for it they're like wow i
can never do that but go for you or good
for you
um
relationship wise like boyfriend yeah i
currently have a boyfriend um
honestly
the past two boyfriends i've had
i've had while i've been dancing and
they've they've gotten used to it like
like bring home the money baby
but uh yeah they get jealous
um my first boyfriend i had during doing
this uh he didn't care at all he didn't
want to know anything about it
and my boyfriend now he cares a little
more doesn't really like it
but
he wants to like kind of know like what
goes on you know
i don't know it's just different yeah
so
when you were a kid did you have dreams
of a different career different life
different path for your life
yeah being an actress actually
um
i got accepted to
one of the top five acting schools nycda
new york conservatory for dramatic arts
but i didn't have the funds to go right
out of high school and that was the only
college i applied for
but and i can still go along that road i
mean i'm living in la so who knows
you never know
that's great
what are the worst and best things about
being a dancer
the best thing the money
obviously yeah um
i don't know i like the attention
um
the pole dancing i like the pool dancing
a lot i mean
it's pool dancing like just by itself is
the best fitness for you
um and you always like
you always go into work you're going to
find something new every day like you're
never going to get bored
as well with other jobs i feel like
i got to go to subway make some
sandwiches today you know
like you're always gonna you're always
gonna have fun and find something
fine maybe find a person with more money
than last night you know
any downsides
yeah a lot um
a lot of guys
trying
when you get back into the rooms they'll
try and take advantage of you and
like i've gotten guys kicked out of
there before like
and then
yeah they're here yeah there's a lot of
just really rude people too like
there's been times where like
girls would just come into the club and
just
be there with by themselves actually
just like a group of them and just sit
there and like just talk down on the
other side another time so be a bunch of
girls that'll come in and just love
getting lap dances from you
so
yeah there can be a lot of hate towards
it
just like every other industry too
though yeah but
yeah
i don't know i don't
i don't know i personally like it i mean
i'm still doing it i'm 25 i've been
doing it for seven years now
but you just got to let
when people just talk [ __ ] upon you or
you just going to let that pass you by
and be like
well
whatever like
i don't know you got everything thick
skin yeah you have to have those just to
say you have to have thick skin and not
let
while people say get to you
just work for your money
all right hillary thank you so much for
coming in and talking to me and good
luck with wherever you go from here
thank you thanks
you